皆さんこういう時ってないですかアイスを食べていましたとおいしいおいしいと食べて
たんですけどもなんか突然飽きちゃってうわーってなって何か別のことをしてて帰って
きたらアイスが溶けてしまっていましたとこういう経験結構あると思うんですよ
air
俺だけごはんな一般的なファン涙をないんですよ僕結構あるんですよそんな溶けて
しまうダイスの使い道今までないと思われてたんですけど
あるんです
動で見たって有名な海外のところでてるんですけども
そんなのジオグラフィックて海外の人が統計たアイスクリームのすごい使い方人見つけ
たらしいんですよ
今回それはちょっといかなってる絶景まあと言ってやってみようと思いますはい1回
やってみますとりあえず信憑性彼が僕もちょっとわからない1回ちょっとやってみよう
と思います
準備する物こちらとケダ s 上がりな想像してみてください僕このパ
目にハーゲンダッツ3つとかしてんですよわぁダメだけだ
どうするか最高級の味を楽しみたいということで励んだ2パターンが水としました
小麦粉中層のがんだけどなんかくれちゃったので作りますがこの3つですも中重曹の
オマケみたいなもんなんで実質アイスに小麦粉を入れて混ぜてレンチする
とっん
[音楽]
cap
ができるらしいです
一般ですよああこれは温度でね&動画美ストラップにびびりました非常に信憑性が低い
アイスじゃあのができませんアギー切っちゃダメですね
いいケツダメなんですけどアイスでパンができるらしいんでちょっとやってみようと
思います熱クッキー
まずアイスですマグカップ1杯分相数だしてください結構溶けてる方だと思うんですよ
ね
一番ありまー最高級アイスが落ちないところは食べますね
うーんまどんどん入れていきます
ちょうどいいぐらいかちょうど良いと思いますはいちょうどいい感が全然やばいは
そんなルチーズ発車
[音楽]
スプーンアイドルメイドいねーっ
もううわあうわあああああ人がずっとしますボール
これじゃないです次です次は小麦粉今使ったマグカップの判断がに入れちゃいましょう
me
そして重曹ちょっとたします数争点がなんて感じなんですけど僕の知らんよこれ
これ重曹入りの小麦粉ができてさっきダイスながらぶっこみますこれを混ぜます
なんかぽいぽいぽいぽぷ多い感じになってきましたよこれええと言いながらヌルヌルに
なったこれを同期に流し込みますとうとうだったんですねこんな年生思ってしまった
はっはっはっ
年間
ロイン寧
[音楽]
これでダメいいはずですねこれを電線路でに頭打ちにしましょう
ます
強い爆発車どうしよういやだいぼができたらこうやったね
あっております
配当いうわけで観戦しますくーっといいかなり膨らんだ気がしますねはい
4をおっ
これ前上背異なってなにこれでも浦和すごいパンぽい
[音楽]
ていた
はい
だから蒸しパンみたいなイメージスイング見た感じでご覧くださいなんか焦げ目場で
吐いちゃってめっちゃいいかパンぽくなってます
溢れて食べさせていただきます宮城ます足が終わってるっていうね
ああパン屋
これ曲げればないファンや2だ
若干まずいわけでちょっとこれはなぁ最初だったね失敗なんですけども
もう動画もフォンティのどこ見たら本当に綺麗なパンになってなんですよ
というわけで今回なので一応相手方になることはわかったんでてからちょっとバランス
感じでちゃんと作ろうと思いますそしてここにわざわざ買ったハーゲンダッツにクリス
チップチョコレートはファーザーズのか下半身だってストロベリー
まず喬巴技術のグリーンティー準備しました
んパン食べて初本当に何か無味のファンだったんですよねこれアイスを変えてチョコ
アイスで作った時と太るメディアして作った時
グリーンズに作った時のパンなんとかどうなで活況を見ていきたいと思いますでは早速
作っていきましょう
手順全く一緒なんでちょっと動画的に省いていきます研修
だーっ十三なんです
けど前よりが使うとしてですね所長じゃなかったっぽくてジュースを使うときは
ちゃんと職業の重曹をつけましょう
ています
よし年前の幕出番増えておりますまっちゃったーっ
あううん
me
ana
はああっ
さあチョコレ
t 2個でいき安武
ファンの記事みたいな解説弾くうちにうまくなってるぞ
[音楽]
う
めっちゃいいわけでパンできましたーー
何がおかしかったんだなんだれーぐバーが入りすぎた抹茶の一角がすごいいい感じで
固く担保になったくらいであとはほぼ失敗する決まったよが明記されてなくてもう感覚
でこの日今度重曹って人に混ぜちゃったところちょっと失敗だった気がしますなには
ともあれ
単価動画ですをいただきます
一番失敗しね地方からいきましょうパンまではいかんけどなんか
食パンの耳じゃない方って感じます
いただけます
出来損ないのパンってかねマジでねちゃんと配分見せて失敗したパンが願いします
そんなの部分的にパサパサってなってるところはちゃんとパンダできますちょっと抹茶
一番してこうぽいからというしますチョコはいただきますチョコも客バランがなっ
ちゃったなぁあっは美味しいですね甘いこのストロベリーかなかったんですけど
ちょっとパンって感じロス4枚続いては抹茶ですっ
な部位がおいしくないともう今回失敗で言っても過言でないレベルですよ
まあならすごい大めっちゃいい感じでパンパンいいけどちゃんと呼吸物いただきます
[音楽]
ブーブーエロ
がグッパパっちょ